hasta hace poco sin Luis ostentaba el
sombrío título de la capital del
asesinato de Estados Unidos y todavía
tiene la segunda tasa más alta del país
este padre de cuatro hijos lo sabe muy
bien su hija mayor fue asesinada en
agosto
mientras viajaba por la calle en la que
estaba fue alcanzada por una bala
perdida supuestamente manejaba en medio
de un tiroteo no estaba haciendo nada
malo no estaba involucrada en la
situación solo estaba conduciendo
25 años y una hija de cinco años ella es
una de las casi 160 Víctimas de la
violencia Armada en San Luis este año su
padre cree que se necesita urgentemente
más control de armas
simplemente somos irresponsables y esta
pandemia que tenemos con las armas en
este país si no tenemos una reforma
integral de las armas sino presionamos a
nuestros representantes y a nuestros
funcionarios públicos
si no hacemos algo constantemente habrá
personas que serán heridas y asesinadas
sin sentido
Missouri tiene la quinta tasa más alta
de muertes por armas de fuego en el país
también tiene algunas de las leyes de
armas más laxas el estado no tiene una
edad mínima para comprar un arma de
fuego y cualquier persona que pueda
poseer un arma legalmente puede portarla
abiertamente sin un permiso
muy bien vas a llenar la sección B del
formulario ahí empieza con tu nombre el
lugar de nacimiento ciudad y estado
puedes abreviar el estado altura peso
sexo fecha de nacimiento Necesito dos
dígitos aquí y cuatro aquí
los distribuidores autorizados como
listenberg deben cumplir con la ley
federal que requiere una verificación de
antecedentes pero para los comerciantes
sin licencia en el estado no existen
tales requisitos
creo que mucho de lo que escuchas Y ves
en cuanto al uso de un arma de fuego de
manera inapropiada no lo hacen los
propietarios legales las leyes son
buenas para las personas obedientes de
la ley pero creo que las leyes son
ignoradas por muchos otros
después del tiroteo masivo en la escuela
primaria Rope nuval de Texas Joe biden
prometió una vez más prohibir las armas
de asalto
para steinberg eso no ayudaría mucho con
la violencia Armada diaria
cada vez que hay un incidente grave con
un arma de fuego alguien quiere prohibir
El rifle de
asalton si lo hiciera por alguna razón
tendría muy poco impacto porque este
rifle se usa en un porcentaje
extremadamente pequeño de incidentes no
va a ser un gran cambio en la violencia
Armada con la violencia Armada en
aumento los estadounidenses están de
acuerdo en la necesidad de un cambio
pero no en la solución los demócratas
creen que la respuesta es más control de
armas mientras que los republicanos
argumentan que la clave es una
vigilancia policial más estricta